the historic public hearings in the
impeachment inquiry into president from
are about to resume this morning we'll
hear from former US ambassador to
Ukraine Murray Ivanovich the career
diplomat has served under six presidents
she was in Ukraine from 2016 until she
was suddenly recalled in May Jovanovic
testified in a closed-door session that
she believed Rudy Guiliani the
president's personal attorney pushed to
have her removed president Trump is
accused of withholding military aid to
pressure Ukraine to investigate
political rivals and yesterday House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi called that bribery
the president denies any wrongdoing
the Face the Nation moderator and senior
foreign affairs correspondent Margaret
Brennan joins us Margaret what can you
tell us about Murray Ivanovich and why
is her testimony so significant well
Anthony ambassador Jovanovic or Masha
has her friends call her as kind of a
tragic figure here at the center this
political drama she served as you said
six presidents in seven countries across
three decades as a veteran ambassador
and Democrats will make the argument
that she represents how the private
interests of the president and his
allies undermined national security she
is someone who was very tough on
corruption when she was serving in
Ukraine that earned her some really
influential enemies including two
individuals were business associates of
Rudy Giuliani who has since been
indicted she will describe in testimony
today a mysterious smear campaign
against her that played out first in
conservative media and then from the
President of the United States son
himself and she will also talk about the
disappointment that none of her bosses
including the Secretary of State ever
came out in defense of her for her
fellow Foreign Service officers she
represents what many see is the
dangerous politicization of the State
Department as an institution Margaret I
know that Miss Giavanna [ __ ] has
described the State Department in these
words hollowed out from within not
exactly sure what that means what are
you hearing about the mood inside the
State Department how
out from within does not sound good no
and those words that the Ambassador used
to describe really do resonate with a
lot of the foreign service officers that
I know when she was saying hollowed out
from within she is talking about the
sense that the professionals that people
like herself as she describes in
testimony feeling betrayed that she
served this country and that in a moment
of need she talks about America not
having her back that she was personally
maligned that she was told by her bosses
that she had so irritated the president
she was being taken off the job even
though she had done nothing wrong so she
was the very first official to defy the
White House order not to comply you know
she put on her high heels and pearls and
showed up at that deposition and she is
seen by many in the rank and file as
someone who if she didn't stand up would
have been allowing for the continuation
of this kind of politicization so her
testimony today is extremely loaded on a
number of different levels
Margaret there is some closed-door
testimony today State Department staffer
David Holmes is testifying he's the one
who allegedly overheard a phone call
between President Trump and EU
ambassador Gordon Sandlin all about
Ukraine and also in Kiev so what's the
significance of his testimony well this
as you said will be behind closed doors
david holmes by all accounts is someone
who should be a credible witness he's
one no less than nine different awards
for his service at the State Department
he served in Afghanistan he served at
the White House now he's in Ukraine and
his testimony will be used by Democrats
to try to directly implicate the
president they will argue that he had
this firsthand
eyewitness account of the president
directing the ambassador and telling him
that he was more interested in
investigating the Biden's than he was
Ukraine and corruption writ large
Republicans were argue he's just another
example of hearsay Margaret Brennan
thank you Margaret